bachelor nation fan favorites Amanda
Stanton and Lauren Bushnell are adorable
besties even working on a business
together and supporting each other in
their relationships we've heard that she
is not single anymore what can you tell
us about that
are you single right now I am I can say
anything for Lauren but yeah okay yes
are you happy for Lauren about where she
is no I'm really happy I think she's
happy I think it's good for her to be
back here in LA she's closer to her
friends she has a lot of support out
here from everyone so I think it's good
for her she's happy going through a
breakup especially a public breakup is
so hard and I think just being there for
her like as far as coming up here and
having girls nights and talking to her
on the phone and just you know I tried
to be there for her as much as they
could she's really happy now her her and
Ben speaking at all are they okay I
don't think they really talked but
they're on good terms et spoke with
Stanton who has her own blog at an event
put on by another Bachelor alum Sarah
heron a photo shoot celebrating the
anniversary of she lifts her charity
organization that empowers young women I
met their own bachelor in paradise and
she's such a sweet her and I just love
that she's using her platform for
something that's so empowering and
something that is near and dear to her
heart so I love to support Sarah
everyone in bachelor nation is beyond
supportive everyone is just so willing
to be involved and contribute in any way
they can't
you